this is the armed forces tournament
tonight the dueling begins up first the
two branch duel where a veteran from the
army and the air force goes up against a
veteran from the navy and the air force
next to me we have a huge weapons crate
with four handles coming out of it
now these are attached to blades from
iconic military history
there's only four blades here because
you are the second duel to take part in
this tournament what i want you guys to
do is come together talk amongst
yourselves and decide which one of these
blades you want to build based solely on
the handle you can see licking five i'm
good with it do five all right brock on
keith all right gentlemen you guys are
gonna be building this
yeah
this is the world war ii air force
survival axe
the united states army air force
survival act was a staple in u.s bomber
planes during world war ii
the standard issue tool featured an ax
head and sharp pike that could be used
to stab and slice through aircraft
aluminum skin after a crash
while its rubber handle provided
protection from electrical shock
although this axe isn't used much today
its legacy lives on in the 2014 video
game the forest
all right gentlemen good luck your time
starts now my name is joe stickel i'm a
retired chief master sergeant for the
oregon international guard
i went in the army right out of high
school and then i serve active guard
with kingsley field klamath falls oregon
so what i decide i'm going to do is make
two billets
i get the first billet in the forge i
figure i can get that heating up and
then i start cleaning my second billet
it's coming along really nice it looks
like it's goodwill
so now i've got to twist it
joe's twisting his billet right now but
using the brush
awesome after i'd cut the excess off i
need to draw some width to it to get the
uh axe shape to it
and then i need to pull out my spike on
the other side
there we go look we got some shape
happening over here on joe once i
drifted in the hole i realized that that
cutting edge is uh width wise is
entirely too thin and that's that's what
they're going to be hitting that thing
into i had plenty of damascus already
done up so what i'm going to do is take
this piece make it into a c-shape make
sure i got long enough for each side
match it up to the cutting edge of the
axe and then i'll forge welded
i'm feeling pressured but i know i'm
gonna get it done
joe's quenching guys
my welds appeared to hold i think it
came out about as good as could be
expected
i have to turn in a finished product
it's tough but there's no quit now i
mean i came here to do a job and that's
what i'm gonna do
so i just go ahead and go with the cord
wrap
i'm happy with the fact that i got
something done it ain't pretty
by no means but i do believe it's a
solid piece
hi my name is dana dupuis i'm 50 years
old i joined the navy out of high school
in 1988 i served for four years and then
i joined the air force reserves and i
retired 2014 as a master sergeant the
amount of steel they gave us was a lot
of steel so i decided to split it dana's
not using very much of this steel wow
that's a huge risk as my stale is
heating in the forge i decide to uh
clean up the other steel and forge weld
this hack up steel in case i need it
just in the off chance uh that billet
blows up or something i have a standby
and i can go right to it
right now i can't get my head around how
i'm gonna make this damn shape as i
started thinking about drilling my
patterns i realized the steel is too
thin to be able to get my raindrop
pattern in i mean honestly if i were
data right now i might start again yeah
it would be a good idea well there he
goes so i tossed that to the side that i
started the other part of my billet that
i've already forged
uh guys dana just scrapped what he's
been working on for the past two and a
half hours
so my game plan right now has got the
new piece start on the spike again kind
of like elongate the center a little
differently and leave it thicker you got
this i got this
i'll get some mild steel i i'll cut off
the raindrop i already have going on and
i'll forge weld and weld a little bit on
some mild stale it's not the best thing
it's not my first choice but it's my
hail mary
dana's quenched not cut into shape yet
but he does have a quenched blade
skates
so i wrap it as best as i can
and i think i got to put something else
so i reach down and i grab blue paint
estate
kind of a homage to blue painters day
and the air force in the navy of blue
tube
five
four three
two
one
vice miss turn off your tools put down
your weapons this round is over yeah
great fight gentlemen great fight
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
i'm gonna take your axes and i'm gonna
be smashing them into these helmets to
see the overall construction and feel of
your blade remember this test is not
about what those axes do to that helmet
what that helmet can do to your axes all
right joe today you are up first are you
ready i'm ready dave all right
my biggest concern is where i welded my
handle on
i mean that junction is at a critical
location when you have that many welds
in something like this when you smash it
into a steel helmet there's obviously
opportunities for failure
well joe that held up you still got a
sharp edge on this thing it's a very
obtuse edge but so is the original you
didn't lose any of those welds nothing
came loose
handle construction
it's actually comfortable to hold on to
all in all it held up beautifully in
this test so good job joe thanks dave
all right dana your turn you ready
no
i don't know what's gonna happen with my
axe
so many things could go wrong for my
construction i'm just hoping that it
doesn't break apart when he strikes
guys
you know what
much as i'd love to test it it's just
not the actual fair it's not what we
asked for pretty far off
and i mean i'm not even sure the
construction the connection here i'd
need to peel this back and it's not what
we asked for
dana i got to tell you you fought really
really hard but uh in the end this is
just isn't the actual shape we were
looking to test and it wouldn't be fair
to test this against your opponent who
actually turned in the axe that was in
the style that we were looking for but
man i got to tell you there's no quit in
you and and i really do appreciate that
dana thank you
well dan i got to start off by saying
you guys had to have chosen the hardest
blade to build in this competition come
hell or high water you decided you were
going to give us a blade so we want to
commend you for that but unfortunately
we can't test your blade equally against
joe's for that reason your time in this
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the forge
floor
all i can say to joe is man i hope you
waited for the air force i love you
brother well joe you know what that
means man you got yourself a seat in the
final round of the armed forces
redeployment tournament you just got
yourself a check for two thousand
dollars congratulations i'm excited to
move on to the next phase but gives me
an opportunity to hopefully be able to
prove what i know i'm capable of doing
how do you feel i wish we could have
tested them both we always wish for it
this challenge was very difficult i can
only imagine what they're going to have
in the next round
you